- [Both] Twins are more--
- Why do you always read my questions?
- Sorry, aren't they our questions?
- No, I let you read
yours, let me read mine.
- Can we share them?
- No.
(upbeat music)
- "The New York Times reported
in 2012 that one in 30
"babies born in the US was a twin."
- That's pretty high.
- Yeah, that seems higher than I thought.
- This is just twins,
that's no identical, so.
- Okay, so yeah.
- We're good.
- We're more unique.
- "A 2006 study by Gary Steinman,
a PhD, found that taller
"women are more likely to have twins."
Our mom's pretty short.
- She is pretty short.
- No, mom's like five feet tall,
so that just doesn't make sense to me.
- That doesn't work.
- I hope we're no like considered tall,
I don't wanna have twins.
- Maybe it allows for
more space in the uterus.
- "In 2011, researchers in
Italy proved via 3D video
"that twins begin to
interact with each other
"in the womb as early as 14 weeks."
- We definitely did.
- You think?
- Oh my god, I feel like
we came in like this.
- What did we talk about
when we were in the womb?
- Do you think were in
like a little bubble
and we're like reaching out
to each other like that?
- Like touching each other?
- Whenever we fell asleep
it's in like same position.
- Yeah, we just go into
like womb position,
that's gotta be, we
definitely were interacting.
- Yeah.
- Roughly 40% of twins
invent their own languages
"spoken only amongst themselves."
- That seems about true, we have
our own language, definitely.
- A few words.
- There's a few words.
- Do you remember specifically
that one time we were in
the ocean on vacation.
- No.
- We were like speaking like gibberish
and this woman came up to us and asked us
where we were from.
- Oh, yes.
- She's like "Where are you from?"
- I do remember that.
- And we're like, "Oh no, we're
just not saying anything."
- We'd like start talking
to each other we'd be like.
Like, not even saying anything.
- There's a few words.
- It's more like a vocabulary
sheet rather than a language.
A word in our language is Blhrie,
spelled B-L-H-R-I-E, and
it's a social outcast.
It's mainly just become a
nickname for our dad now.
- [Both] "Identical twins do not have
"the exact same fingerprints."
- Yes, we knew that.
- We knew that, we knew that.
- "Although they have
nearly-identical DNA,
"fingerprint patterns are
not based on DNA alone."
- So we can't do crimes for each other."
- As long as we wear gloves,
if we're ever gonna kill
anyone, we'd be fine.
- "A UK study from 2005 found
that dressing twins in the
"same clothes could cause
stigma and social isolation
"from the twins' peers."
- I mean we're wearing the same thing now.
- Are we anti-social?
- Like a little bit.
- We like, switched
schools in fourth grade
and my mom dressed us exactly alike,
and the kids like went nuts.
We made all of our
friends based off of that.
- We didn't wanna look identical at all.
- Not at all.
- "Twins are less likely than
non-twins to get married."
That feels true.
- "Some interpret these
findings to mean that
"since they were raised
with a partner of sorts,
"twins have less desire to be married."
- So many of our friends
have said this to us.
- 'Cause it's like you're my soul mate.
- Right, I know, like
you're my number one.
- My boyfriend will be like,
"Oh you're my favorite person."
I'll be like, "Oh, you're
my second favorite person."
- I also always envisioned
that when I buy a house,
it would be with Benny.
- You're just so used, like you feel like
you've been in a relationship
your entire life.
- You really do.
- I just don't wanna get married
'cause I don't wanna get married,
but I also have Benny, so it's okay.
- [Both] "It's possible for a
woman to have fraternal twins
"with different fathers."
- "Some research suggests
as many as two percent
"of fraternal twins could
have different dads."
Yeah, 100%.
- Yeah, totally.
- "Sperm can stave alive
for up to five days
"after sex under the right conditions.
"If a woman releases two eggs
rather than the usual one,
"and if she had sex with more than one man
"within a five day window,
it's possible that sperm
"from different men can
fertilize each egg."
- That is the weirdest thing ever.
- That's gotta be more
fun to explain though.
When someone's like, "Oh are you a twin?"
You're like, "Yeah, I am, let me tell ya."
- "We're also half siblings."
That's like a riddle.
- Alright, do you feel
like we learned anything?
- I think I learned a lot,
I mean like some of them
were kind of shocking, something new.
- I learned so much about twins.
I just sort of knew who I was and now
I know so many more things about twins
all over the world.
- I feel like a lot of these
were really interesting.
- Don't mess with twins.
- Yeah.
- Especially identical twins.
- The murders.
- I learned a little bit more about twins.
But I'm not leaving here totally aghast.
- You're not wowed by twins?
- I love twins.
- Me, too.
(upbeat rock music)